the protests that have been challenging
democratic decisions have now faced an
attack themselves
pro-government supporters have stormed
the growing protest camp on colombo's
seafront a shame to be a citizen of this
country a shame right now to be born
into this country
slashing tents and beating
anti-government demonstrators in
retaliation vehicles and commercial
buildings have been destroyed and a
number of mp's houses have been set
alight
the military attempted to push back
and after being accused of standing by
police have used tear gas and the water
cannon to disperse crowds
but some soon turned on them
[Applause]
in an attempt to appease escalating
anger sri lanka's prime minister has now
resigned mahinda rajapaksha had
initially stood his ground when the
country's president who's also his
brother had asked him to leave
but today marked a violent shift in the
demonstrations too ugly to ignore
it it is very unclear where will this
end uh because uh now
people are like
like now they're crazy now they are
searching for the uh rajabaksha
supporters rajabaksha things
this challenge on democracy isn't
welcome this was a previous attempt to
quell the anger
[Applause]
but the desperate shortage of fuel and
rising prices have led to hundreds more
joining the movement
with the government accused of plunging
the country into the worst financial
crisis in decades one leader resigning
isn't enough protesters want the
president gone too
ashnaharenac sky news